hateful peacemakers that's the focus of
tonight's
angle the rule is that you don't
negotiate with terrorists right you
don't give them an inch because they'll
take a mile in the case of Hamas we know
they'll use a lull in the fighting to
burrow in resupply and Stoke more
anti-israel sentiment
worldwide to survive Hamas needs a break
in the action they know it and Hezbollah
knows it now remember their goal is to
destroy Israel period and they'll use
endless Pro Palestinian propaganda to
keep Hamas alive which keeps their dream
of destroying the Jewish people alive
and despite claiming to be staunch
supporters of Israel the White House is
playing right into their hands Secretary
of State Tony blinkin flew to Israel
again with a clear message to Netanyahu
stop supposedly they just want more time
to get more hostages released of course
we all want the hostages released but as
the angle predicted Hamas is using its
hostages as bargaining chips releasing a
few yesterday which the administration
cited was proof that their efforts were
paying off and then Anonymous
Administration officials told CNN that
in conversations with Netanyahu Biden
has warned that Israel will be judged
harshly by the International Community
if it doesn't take steps to
significantly ease human Arian suffering
and minimize Palestinian civilian deaths
now this is what you have to understand
Biden's team is leaking these details
because they know that they're losing
political support at home from his Pro
Palestinian voters who as we've seen
have taken to the streets because
they're trying the Biden people are
they're trying to send signals of we
hear you to the pramas wing of their own
party but are Biden's calls for this
tempor orary Paws actually working well
more from CNN Netanyahu explicitly
rejected some of those calls on Friday
as blinkin visited Israel and met with
the Israeli War cabinet the Prime
Minister specifically said that his
government opposed any temporary
ceasefire in Gaza unless Hamas freed all
the hostages it holds well of course
Netanyahu is making the right call for
his people and the survival of his
Nation the idea that you can trust Hamas
to have any humanitarian instincts is
absurd they're still firing into Israel
Hamas has been uh using mortars to hit
this area and also small Rockets just a
lot of shrapnel marks on this wall you
can see all of these holes here all of
this on the side of a kindergarten it's
painted these colors because normally in
times of War before Hamas committed the
massacre against Southern Israel kids
were going to school here this was a
kindergarten that was used by the
southern
Community most have evacuated since then
uh but you can see see there are still
soldiers and and police officers in this
area because it sits just over the
border from the Gaza
Strip but don't expect far-left
Democrats on Capitol Hill to care about
what's happening and still happening to
Israel 17 of them signed on to a
resolution by Corey Bush that reads like
it could have been written by that
Hezbollah leader himself calling for an
immediate deescalation and ceasefire in
Israel and occupied
Palestine and for other house Democrats
are calling for a straight
ceasefire and over in the Senate what's
happening well when pressed on his view
of what Israel should do tricky dick
Durban used his typical weasel words is
a ceasefire needed
now I think it is at least under in the
context of both sides agreeing oh this
is is rids ridiculous he knows that
Israel is not agreeing and can agree to
a ceasefire but Durban also knows that
the political price his party could pay
in next year's election is significant
so he's kind of trying to have it both
ways there well when I was thinking
about this today I thought isn't it a
good time to ask this question why have
Democrats taken such a different
approach with the war in Ukraine it is
impossible to explain to my constituency
why when the ukrainians are in the midst
of fighting and dying every single day
for their nation that this Congress
somehow or another managed to pass a
spending Bill and not include more
funding for the Ukrainian
cause now where's The Peacemaker
thousands of lives have been lost at
least 9,000 civilians but probably more
in Ukraine and hundreds of billions of
dollars in damage that you know we're
going to be called on to fix and
yesterday its own defense Chief in
Ukraine said the situation is at a
stalemate so why didn't Biden call for a
humanitarian pause there at any point in
the last what 21 months or so well
there's plenty of suffering and more us
funding is only going to ensure that the
suffering
continues if there were ever a case
where interested parties should call for
a pause to conduct negotiated settlement
Ukraine is it in fact last year when
progressives on the hill did urge Biden
to negotiate with Russia boy they were
told quick to back off and uh they've
been quiet ever since on Ukraine but
with Israel it's different well the
truth is the squad types don't believe
Israel should be allowed to defend
itself even though a month has now
passed since Hamas carried out that
attack slaughtering 1400 innocent
civilians now we should offer military
advice there if asked but otherwise stay
out of this counter offensive and the
advice that we do give should not be
based on on what Democrats elections
prospects are next
year but when it comes down to it Biden
doesn't really have a foreign policy
they have a plan for Biden's
reelection and they do just whatever
they think is going to help with that
the White House knows the hard left
hates Israel and they're afraid that the
war is going to hurt them politically
but the hard left likes zinski so that
war can just go on forever as long as
the Democrats are concerned they don't
care but a real president would focus on
what is best for the United States well
of course we don't have a real president
we have a figurehead president
surrounded by folks who want him
reelected so they can make down the road
a lot of money as lobbyists and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else